[Applause]
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
broly, pa
Good morning right now,
everyone, Kyan and Magical Smile Danny,
I've seen the color if
it's not
Magicola alone.  What are
you going to do? A village that shines more brightly than
it does now A regular village on the radio Even Burleigh's obsessed with the match
Iron Frill has even been declared a rival
Well, if you
look at the miracle up of Inumajiru and see it in Francais Wonderful Up, it's not like it's in the Chin district, but it's going
to be 4 pieces for the next
one.
Taku
sugoca Hey, Lily-chan, do you have a specific plan
?
If you win a prize in a local or live broadcast that is held with your mouth,
you will participate in the national competition that will be held in Tokyo at the end of the year
.
When will I go to the world of Isono program Alfe
good
tni
[Music]
[Applause]